here's patrick mahomes from over the
weekend he had a 15 in the mahomey's
foundation golf tournament in hawaii and
he was
asked in a sit down with bleacher report
what he thinks about
aaron rodgers entering possibly the afc
west
i mean obviously it'd be it'd be awesome
i mean to have that challenge every
single
every every two year times a year every
single year
it would be a great great opportunity i
mean he uh he's a heck of a football
player he's been doing it for a long
time that i've i've watched play and
learned a lot from absolutely but uh
definitely if he came to the afc west it
would just make it a little tougher for
us but
we were up for the challenge
so uh patrick mahomes what else is he
gonna say oh god
i don't want her please don't oh no
don't
oh no please we don't want him here
somewhere else it's so scary
we can't compete with him i know right
yeah i
but it would be something it would be
something if we see aaron rodgers
in the afc west along with justin
herbert and patrick mahomes
and and and it's either the broncos or
possibly the raiders now we don't know
what the raiders are thinking at this
point they could be lurking for
as i said last week a possible out of
the blue effort to get russell wilson as
of tomorrow when the cap hit
for the seahawks would drop from 39
million down to 13 million maybe they're
thinking about trying to get aaron
rodgers
we know that rogers wants to go west and
the broncos and the raiders are on his
wish list along with the 49ers that
door's closed but
broncos and raiders still open chris and
it's kind of late in the day
as the off-season goes to make a
dramatic change like that but with aaron
rodgers you
you you if it's if it's if it's week one
you make it work yeah
that's right i mean if they called today
or tomorrow and you know got
got a conversation going and hearing the
things they like as far as the trade
package you're right you would make that
as much as it'd be like man we've
already been working and we've had all
these zoom sessions
and we'd like him to have been a part of
that to learn the offense and all those
things
yeah that's one where you just you swipe
it all into the rug and go who the hell
cares i mean if he went to denver
it would be unbelievable it'd be a game
changer it really would
first off i the first thing that comes
to my head is just go
holy crap every good quarterback and
football is in the afc other than tom
brady
and russell wilson i mean the nfc would
be depleted of quarterbacks
that's the first thing i think of of
course the division matchups twice a
year
all that but it's a game changer in the
afc in general
if he goes to denver and i think we both
agree denver's one of those teams that's
like
teetering on taking that proverbial next
step
or you know raising to the next level
whatever you want to say
denver is is close they're one of those
teams i can certainly see
make a jump if they got rogers with
those wide receivers
and that defense that's pretty damn good
already
you know it just changes everything it
changes the dynamics of the afc west it
might change the dynamic of
kansas city's stronghold on being a one
or two seed
on a yearly basis here for the next few
years that's where it gets interesting
to me it really changes that that part
of it
and and let me make a plea right now to
our friends watching on peacock or nbcsn
or sky sports
swiping under the rug has already been
covered you don't need to email them
okay
something else yeah sorry established
simsism
d don't need deep in there right there
again right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports